is there anybody else they can talk
communicate with people and imitate
their facial expressions some robots
even look human at the Science Museum in
London visitors can get up close and
personal with humanoids and it can be an
emotional experience coming face to face
for the mechanical human has always been
a little scary over the centuries each
generation experienced this afresh as
new ways of Technology heralded new
robotic forms that sense of an ease of
something you cannot quite put your
finger on goes to the heart of our or
should I say your long relationship with
robots Robo thesbian is one of the
exhibition star attractions this
life-size humanoid robot was designed to
communicate and entertain the science
museum is devoting an entire exhibition
to this form of artificial intelligence
simply called robots the show comprises
more than a hundred humanoid pods with
humanoid robots there's this desire I
think first of all to build them for
entertainment I think you've always just
been entertained by this idea of
creating mechanical people it's humanoid
robots is also a way of demonstrating
our technological advancements so human
bodies amazingly complex are trying to
recreate it through technology available
to us has always been a challenge for
people the exhibition robots boasts the
largest collection of humanoid robots
ever assembled and even includes a few
of the first models dating from the late
Middle Ages like this 16th century
mechanized monk their movements were
based largely on clockwork so they were
repetitive and predictable they couldn't
react with the you know the real world
as we do but it's the basis on which a
lot of modern-day robots were founded
today's robots also showcased
technological capabilities this code
amyloid communication Android is highly
realistic she's never been seen outside
Japan before these days robots are
employed in many areas of our lives in
industry and research as toys even as
performers
what looks so easy took years of work by
robotic engineers to achieve if it works
at all there are so many moving parts so
there are 12,000 parts in this robot and
we have to make every one of them and if
one of them is wrong and nothing works
so it's extremely complicated the
relationship between man and machine has
interested artists for centuries science
fiction films reflect the human longings
and desires of their time whether
fascinating or terrifying researchers
must also consider the potential social
impact when deciding what the robots of
the future should do to think about you
know the benefits that this technology
might bring to our society also the
consequences and to imagine you know
what sort of future do we want with
robots because I think it is a big
question for our society to have to
think about not just humanoid robots for
all robotic technologies however
intelligent robots are still machines
they remain an expression of our hopes
fears and dreams even if the boundaries
between humans and humanoids are
increasingly blurred
[Music]
[Music]